♪ ♪ ♪
- Mettre des mots et des images
sur une périe e difficile.
Le Musée royal de l'Ontario
présente une exposition
d'oeuvres faites par des enfants
pendant la pandémie.
Le musée en a reçu plus
de 2000 : des dessins,
des peintures, des chansons
et même des sculptures.
Considérées dans leur ensemble,
ces oeuvres dressent un portrait
de la pandémie vue
par les enfants.
JULIE TOMÉ, éduc. scientifique
Musée royal de l'Ontario
- Les jeunes, ils sont honnêtes.
T'sais, ils ne vont pas cacher
comment ils se sentent.
- Si plusieurs oeuvres ont
pour thème la crise sanitaire,
certaines font écho à d'autres
moments marquants de 2020, comme
le mouvement Black Lives Matter.
Cette jeune artiste torontoise
a peint un autoportrait
pendant les manifestations.
C'est la première fois que
le Musée royal de l'Ontario
expose des oeuvres soumises
par le grand public.
Une soixantaine de créations
seulement ont été sélectionnées
pour être exposées en salle,
mais toutes les autres
sont disponibles en ligne.
C'est le cas d'une photo
envoyée par cette adolescente.
RYANN FINEBERG
- Nos perspectives sont
quelquefois pas toujours
entendues et c'est très
important qu'on utilise
nos talents pour faire
des choses grandes comme cela.
- Une introspection
qui interpelle visiblement
les adultes.
Le musée espère que cette
exposition gratuite permettra
d'encourager les enfants
à y remettre les pieds.
- C'est une expérience
qu'on a tous vécue et d'avoir
quelque chose à partager
dans un espace avec de l'art
fait par les enfants,
je pense que c'est bien.
- L'exposition est présentée
jusqu'au 27 mars.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, Toronto.